every day I Drive by and there's this
giant billboard I'm sure everyone here
has seen it it's out front it's all of
you guys eating yes I guess that's the
way to promote the show I guess people
have these you know these thoughts about
like the coal castes they're all
together they got to be doing something
yeah right and they saw they had this
idea of you guys eating we eat together
it's kind of these guys are kinda like a
family you know so it's a it's a thing
that we do together but it's it's tricky
it's tricky acting and eating at the
same time because you have to time the
bite with the joke sometimes you choke
and then when the camera cuts away you
can spit your food out but then when it
comes back on you you're chewing you
know you're really chewing in you know
it's funny I've never thought about this
but you guys do that a lot on this show
where they want the actors don't have an
action yes they're doing you've got the
old adages you can't come onto a scene
with just people sitting there doing
nothing right right because that's not
reality predominantly so we have to be
doing something so eating is a big thing
if you watch sitcoms a lot you'll see
people eating a lot I've noticed on Will
and Grace in Eric McCormack is always
stirring a pot of he's always there
stirring a pot
and that's his action always and tasting
it and then maybe equip and yeah always
stirring like he's got like a sauce that
he's always making over in the kitchen
and then people characters come in and
out he's like you wiseguy stirring
he's literally stirring the pot and
stirring the pot nicely done I'll see
you for that yeah but you know what's
interesting I didn't think it was that
hard and I was curious what is the
technique if you're if you're trying to
eat and act at the same time could you
show us what it is we brought some we
just brought some food and I thought
maybe you go Andy do you want some there
it's just we're gonna well yeah you do
so let me teach you my food acting class
techniques so we're in a scene together
we don't seem together the first thing
we're just talking Donnie just like play
around their food you're looking at you
know you're kind of like mixing your
food you know you put it in you'll say a
couple of lines you know what I mean
okay now the cameras on you you said
your joke it's about to cut away and you
do this and then it cuts away when
you're chewing your journal and you spit
it out and you spit out and I was saying
but now you're not really you know
nobody like I do right so yeah but now
you've said that it's ruined all sitcoms
for me because all I'm thinking about is
spit it out but you just you kind of
fake it like what I'll do is so this
looks like a really big bite right so it
looks like I'm about to do this the
camera will cut away and I'll quickly
throw it away
and I'll just take whatever comes back
to me and Rick you know you get it yeah
I think I get it try and ask me Oh I'll
do a line after like Jimmy allowed you
know I'll just I'll make up a line yeah
you ask me something like hey Conan
Conan how was your what's going on in
the second oh you know I got to tell you
something
what's amazing you just took a bite you
didn't even do anything
no the point the rice was better the
rice was better than I thought it would
be
so think that's what I would be doing I
have to tell you I come from a big Irish
Catholic family and we justwhen use this
food in front of us we go I would get
more interested in the hamburger than in
the scene I was playing so I'd be even
in the drama there'd be like Conan's the
murderer I would just plow through my
food yeah cool that that was those good
want to get you on camera eating but see
I got nothing in my mouth that's the
technique that's the technique you're
like a magician
it's the least impressive thing to
everyone so it's yeah yeah and then
yep let me get this even better now
that's pretty subtle that's pretty
subtle this is a reason I've never been
asked to be on a sitcom never will
you